[Music]
hey everyone my name is arjun and today
i'm going to be showing you guys
12 dynamic opening traps so before we
get started
i just wanted to let you guys know
something and there are a lot of opening
traps such as the laster's trap the
legal trap
and lots of others like that but the
only thing that i have against these
traps is that they rarely ever come up
in games
and this is usually because they're so
well known that most people will know
how to avoid them
so today the 12 opening traps i'm going
to show are traps that are much more
likely to actually come up in your games
and with that out of the way let's get
on to the first trap
so this trap occurs in the london system
and it begins like this
g4 knight f6
knight f3 e6 bishop f4
and this marks the beginning of the
london system so the london doesn't
necessarily need to come up from this
move order
it can also come up where black has
played d5 at the beginning
and generally some common plans for both
sides
include white will play e3 bishop d3
knight d2
and c3 and meanwhile black will most
likely play d5
c5 bishop to e7 or to d6
and his knight most likely to c6 or to
d7
and for this trap to occur black will
have to play c5
and this isn't a bad move or anything
but white will play e3 here
and the idea is that if black takes
white will take back with the pawn
and white's also going to play bishop d3
if he's allowed to
so black plays b6 here just intending to
fan head with a bishop
and here normally white could play
bishop d3 which is a perfectly fine move
but in order to set this trap white
should play knight to d2
and here black plays bishop to b7 just
natural developing the bishop
he's not worse or anything yet but if he
messes up on the next move then he
definitely will be
so white plays knight to c4 and this is
a very cunning move here because it
makes a threat on d6
and it's actually very difficult to see
that ahead of time especially in blitz
games
so the most obvious way of stopping this
knight to d6 threat is to play d5
and this falls into the trap but some
other options include to play d6
and if this happens white should just
take on c5
then if black takes back white should
just trade queens and he's a bit better
he's not winning or anything
but he does have some advantage after
say knight c to e5
and of course in this position if he
takes to the b pawn then you can take on
d6 just winning a pawn
so d6 isn't a very good move and the
best move here is actually just to play
knight c6 ignoring the threat
so if white tries to play knight g6
black will recapture
takes and he'll play knight e4 kicking
the bishop back
black will castle and it's about equal
but all these moves are good but we're
focusing on the trap here
so instead black might play d5 and this
falls into the trap
white should play knight c to e5 which
actually creates two hard to
hide to see threats and one of them is
bishop to b5 the other is knight to g5
so if black just plays a random move
let's say h6 white will play bishop to
b5
and the idea is that if black plays
knight to c6
you can take take take and you'll win an
exchange
and you're already up a piece actually
but anyway
if black plays either knight to d7 white
will take
black will take back and white will play
knight to e5
and this is winning
so black won't play h6 if he plays a6
however trying to stop the bishop b5
threat
you should play knight to g5 and this
just double attacks f7
and there's actually no good way of
stopping that if black plays something
like queen to e7 for example
then white can just take
so therefore you might think there's no
way to stop both threats but black's
best try is probably to play something
like knight to d7
and after knight d7 white should play
bishop b5 threatening to play if black
just does nothing
the same idea as before
so black is probably going to play a6
here because it prevents white from
taking on d7
at least without losing this bishop and
now here white actually has only one
move of retaining his advantage
and that's to play knight g5 which is a
very powerful move
so black should obviously just take on
b5 that was his intention he should just
follow through with that
and now white should take on f7
this attacks the queen and the rook
which is a fork so black should probably
play something like queen e7
protecting his queen now white will take
on h8
and if white's knight is able to get
back somehow for example like that
then he'll be up in exchange and he
should be much better or winning
but obviously black isn't going to let
white do that so
black might try h6 trying to cut off the
knight's lifeline
but in this case white can play knight
to g6 and if queen d8
knight f3 and this knight will escape to
e5 probably
next so h6 is not a good move because it
undefends this crucial g6 square
so another option to try and get rid of
this g5 lifeline
is for black to play knight e4 but
after 94 what can what white can play is
he can just go queen h5
and the idea is that if g6
then white can take on h7 so if knight
takes here
then white should just take on g6 if
knight f7 this is the only way of
protecting the knight
white can play bishop g5 which is
another cool tactic
and of course if black takes here i can
just take
and hear another tactic actually he'll
take on f8
and here knight f7 winning the queen
next move so after king e7
then knight takes g5 so that's one
pretty long line
so anyway so white's gonna play queen
or not knight f7 he's going to play
queen to h5
so after g6 again queen h7
and if white if black takes to the queen
you can just take here and the knight
will capture on g6
after pretty much any move by black
actually if you
take castles you can just take
so that's how you refute knight e4 and
there's only one more real good option
for black
and that's to play just some nothing
move and one example of that would be
rook a7
and the easiest way of winning this
position is to just play knight takes h7
which is another tactic within this one
tactic
and the concept is if black takes
you can play queen to h5 check and
of course if king d8 then you can just
take this pawn
this knight and if you play something
like g6
black white should just take king over
knight f7
and the idea is that once black's king
moves
you can just take this knight for free
and the only other real try black has
once he reaches this position
is to play e5 and after e5
white should just take most likely black
should obviously take back there's no
other reasonable move
and now the easiest is to play knight h7
and of course if black doesn't take
then this g6 lifeline is once again
available
and if he does recapture i can just play
queen h5 and this is another fork
actually a triple four technically
so whatever black does here if he plays
like this for example
um white should just take the knight and
he's recaptured his peace and his knight
will escape soon
so that is this london trap and this is
probably my favorite trap out of all of
these and it's also probably my favorite
trap in general actually
so this next trap occurs from the
sicilian defense which is a very popular
opening
so it's for white again and starts as e4
c5 knight f3 knight c6 d4
so the open sicilian g takes c takes d4
knight takes d4 knight f6 knight c3
and d6 so this is the best move
but this does not fall into the trap
so if black plays a move g6 then he's
already fallen into the trap he's not
losing but he's slightly worse
and the idea that white has is he's
going to take on c6
so black could take with the d pawn but
that wasn't his point because you can
just take back
and play something like bishop c4 and
white's a bit better because he's a head
in development and black can't castle
but most people would play b take c6 and
white's going to play e5
just attacking this knight and the
knight has three possible options
knight g8 is clearly not good because it
just retreats to the knight starting
square
white should just continue development
here
knight h5 is also not a good move
because it puts a knight on the side and
white is obviously better here and he
can play something like bishop c4
and the last move is to play knight d5
which is actually the worst of the three
moves so
white plays knight takes d5 c takes d5
queen d5
and once black plays rook b8 he might
have seen all of this and the idea that
black has
is that this bishop right here it's it's
tied to this b2 pawn
this bishop is tied to this g2 pawn if
black ends up playing bishop to b7
and black's also going to develop to g7
and then he'll castle
and it seems like black position is
pretty good here it seems like the
position should be about equal
because black clearly has a lot of
counter play even though he is down a
pawn
but here white has a killer move which
is e6
and this is actually very difficult to
spot from pretty far away especially in
the opening
so if black takes with either pawn
actually white should play queen e5 and
this forks both rooks
so if black plays something like queen
d6 to try to protect one rook
white will just take the other one
so if black doesn't recapture on d6 well
obviously if he plays d6
then he'll just take on f7 white's much
better
and if he plays f6 then the idea is that
white can just play something like
bishop f4
and if black tries taking the rook
taking this pawn
white has this really cool move castle's
queen side
and i just really like this move because
it's castling and it's attacking this
pawn which is pretty cool
so if black tries to play something like
for example rook b7
then white can just play bishop a6 and
once blacksmith rook moves away you can
just take on c8 and take on d7 and white
is completely winning
so the third trap i have to show today
is also
coming from the sicilian defense and
it's in the dragon specifically the 11
fish variation
so it starts with e4 c5
knight f3 d6 d4
c takes d4 knight takes d4 knight f6
knight c3 g6 and this begins the dragon
variation
so the most popular move here is to play
bishop e3 and white's ideas he'll play
f3
queen d2 castle's queen side
the bishop will probably go to c4 and
he'll play f4
h4 and g4 and he'll try to attack on the
king side
but to set this trap white can't play
this line so instead he plays the move
f4
it's a very powerful move that can
easily win games very quickly
so black might play bishop g7 which is a
natural move
and here white should play e5
so if black takes here he takes
and now black only has one move which
retains relative equality
and that is to play knight after d7
however this move
isn't very appealing to black players
here because you can play e6
and the idea is that if you move your
knight back somewhere
then you can take on f7 and if you take
the knight then you've got this isolated
e pawn
and of course if you take with the king
then you'll you have the isolated epon
and you also can't castle
so most people won't play knight d7 and
there's two other options
there's actually three other options
there is knight to h5
but this is also not a good move so what
white wants to do is he wants to play g4
trapping the knight but the problem is
why can't black can play bishop e5
so to make this move even better white
should play bishop to b5 check
before that and the idea is that no
matter which piece black blocks with the
knight
or the bishop let's see blocks of the
bishop
black should play white should play g4
now
and the idea is now bishop takes e5 here
is kind of pointless because you can
just take on h5 and the d4 knight is not
hanging
if black tries to take on b5 here you
can just take with actually either
knight it doesn't really matter
and you're up a piece
so black should play something like for
example queen to c7
after which white can just play knight
f3 protecting this pawn and then he'll
take this
this knight next move
so that is how you refruit knight h5 and
there's two other options
knight g4 and
knight f2 and knight to d5
so if he plays knight to g4 the idea is
that
white can play bishop b5 and there's no
good moves for black here
if he plays knight to c6 you can take
if he takes you can take and you're
going to win some material
if he blocks with either piece on g7 you
can just take this knight
it blocks with the bishop the same thing
and if you place king f8 then white has
an even better move which is to play
knight e6
and no matter which way black takes
white will take
on g8 and he wins the queen and in this
case also is checkmate
so what black should do is he should
just play something like this
after which white can just take the
queen
so knight g4 also doesn't work and he
has one last
remaining try if he plays something like
knight to d5
white will play bishop b5 as he's been
doing in some other variations
and of course if you block on d7 with
either piece you can win this knight
and it's the same story if you block
with this knight because you can just
take
if you play knight to c6 then you can
just go with the same fork mechanism i
showed earlier
where you will win this rook next move
so the only other option remaining for
black is for him to castle
so what white should do now is he should
play castles here and the idea is that
now that his rook is on the same line as
black's king
he has a lot of mating and forking
opportunities so just one example here
is if white is black plays something
like knight to c6
then white can play queen f3 and that
just forks the knight
and the f7 pawn so what black should do
is you should just take on e5
and he should just be down a piece and
that's just one example of what can
happen if he's not careful
the next trap i have to show also comes
from the sicilian defense but this time
it comes from the allopin variation
so it starts off with e4 c5
knight f3 g6 c3 and the idea is white
wants to play c
d4 and build a big center so white black
just plays knight c6
natural move d4 and here
uh the the most common moves are for
black to play c takes d4
and knight f6 but since this is a trap
black plays an inferior move which is
bishop to g4
and it seems very natural it seems as
though black is just going to
pin this knight and therefore indirectly
putting pressure on d4
however white has a very strong move
here that's a d5
so this doesn't look like a super
special move at first
but it actually gets a very good
position
if black plays knight to e5 white will
actually just take
and of course if you take back on d on
e5 then
queen takes g4
and if bishop takes d1 then bishop b5
check and he's forced to block with the
queen after which you can take
king d8 you can take on f7
king here and just take on d1 followed
by capturing on h8 after which whites up
a lot of material
so if he doesn't play knight e5 he only
has two other reasonable options and
those two
knight a5 and knight b8
so if he plays knight to a5 white should
just play b4 and this actually just
traps the knight straight away
so if you take black white will take
back
and if black moves his knight anywhere
you can just take it
and even if he doesn't move his knight
you can just take it next move
so knight a5 is clearly bad and the only
other option is to play knight b8 and
it's never a good sign when retreating
your knight to b8
is the best move and what what white
should do from here is he should just
develop his pieces
and once white when black brings his
piece back you can just develop your
other pieces and white's ahead a bit in
development
and he has a better position
so trap number five occurs in the
queen's gamut accepted
which is not a very popular opening the
queen's game declined is more popular
but it's this opening still does happen
quite often
so d4 d5 in this case white plays knight
f3 knight f6
it doesn't really matter and he plays c4
now so c4
d takes c4 and he plays e3 just trying
to recapture this piece
black plays g6 white takes
black just develops his bishop and white
checks here
so this isn't the best move instead what
white should do
he should probably just castle although
he's not worse or anything after queen
queen to a4 so
here black has several options as to how
he can stop the check
you can play c6 knight c6
knight d7 bishop d7 or queen d7 those
are the main reasonable options
and actually out of those only one of
them survives and that is the move c6
after which the position is about equal
so let's go over the other
options if black plays knight to c6
then white can play knight e5 which is a
double attack for c6
and f7
and what black should do here is he
should just castle after which
you can take take and here white should
just continue developing
instead of capturing the pawn but say
castles
so instead of playing knight to c6 black
can play knight to d7
and this is actually a much worse move
because white has this move bishop f7
so black could take on f7 but the
problem with this is he'll play knight
to g5 and from here
if king to g8 is played then you can
play queen b3
and if you block you can capture
the king moves and queen f7 checkmate
after king f8 or king y8 the move is the
same white will play knight to e6
and if king f8 then this just forks the
queen and king
so white wins a queen
and if king e8 then knight e6 actually
just traps the queen
so the queen can't escape
so the best move in this position is for
black to play king f8
but after this white can just bring his
bishop back and the king can't castle
it's very weak
and white has rushed one upon which is
great
so if black tries playing instead of
knight c6 or knight d7 instead if he
plays bishop to d7
will white can you see he can play queen
to b3 which is another fork
and if black castles which is the best
move
white will just take on b7 and if he
protects b7 by playing say b6
you can take on f7
the only other option remaining to black
is to play queen to d7
after which white will play bishop takes
f7
so if black takes on f7 this is a really
bad move because
knight e5 and no matter where the king
moves
black will take on d7 white will take on
d7 winning the queen
so the best move after bishop to
bishop takes off seven is to play king
f8
and white should just retreat his queen
somewhere maybe to c2 or to d1
and the bishop is still immune because
of knight e5
and just to note if he plays knight f to
d7 which is very unlikely uh black can
just white can just do the exact same
thing that he did if knight b to d7 was
played he can take on f7
if king takes then knight to g5
and here black should play king f6
trying to avoid what happened there
and although he is down material black's
king is incredibly weak
and he should be able to mate him quite
soon
so this next trap is called the marshall
trap and it occurs from the petrov
defense
and this one is for black so e4
e5 knight f3 knight f6 and this is the
petrov defense
so white plays knight takes e5 black
plays d6
knight f3 knight takes e4 so
white plays d4 then black might play d5
so then bishop d3 bishop d6 castles
castles these are all very natural moves
and in order to play the marshall trap
the plane must have must
continue like this white plays c4 which
is the most common move
and then bishop g4 and this move
initiates the marshall trap
so the best move here is to play
something like c6
where the position is about equal but
instead black plays bishop g4
which is a slight inaccuracy but it sets
a deadly trap
so white is going to take this pawn
which is very natural and black plays f5
and the main idea of playing f5 is just
to protect this pawn
and also it activates this rook and it's
also just generally an aggressive move
so white should play move like knight b
to d2
and black can't really use the trap here
but if
if white plays a very natural move rook
to e1
then he's already fallen into the trap
and this trap here goes bishop takes h2
and what white should do here is he
should play king f1
which protects his pawn and black's a
bit better but he's not winning or
anything
but the most natural moves to play king
takes h2 after which
black will take on f2 and it doesn't
really matter where white
queen moves here any square will do but
let's say he goes queen to e2
then knight takes d3 queen takes d3
forced
and bishop f3 and here the trap might
start to make sense here
because if you capture with either the
queen or the pawn
queen h4 works the rook and you can win
the rook
so black white shouldn't take the piece
and if you play something like king g1
trying to escape this fork
then white can either just attack the
rook or
bring his bishop back like this and he's
somewhat better here
so the seventh trap is called the
rubinstein trap
and this trap is especially useful for
faster time controls
so this trap is played for black
and starts with e4 c5 g4
ctx d4 c3 gtx c3 knight c3
and this is the smithmore gambit
so knight c6 knight f3 e6
bishop c4 queen c7 castles knight f6
so this is all normal so far white plays
black white plays queen e2
and this is a theme that occurs in many
different openings
and it's let black plays knight to g4
which is a good move on its own even if
it didn't set a trap
and here what what black's idea is is
he's threatening h2
just playing aggressively and he's also
threatening to play knight d4
which sets a pretty cool trap so
what white should do is he should play
something like knight b5 which stops the
trap and attacks the queen
but to fall into the trap you can play
anything and one of these moves
is to play h3 and the reason this falls
into the trap is because black will play
knight d4
so if white takes the knight then white
can play then black and black queen h2
checkmate if black just moves his queen
somewhere
well white what black should do is he
should just take
and if he plays if black if white takes
back
then queen h2 checkmate
and of course if he tries to stop the
mate by taking here for example
black should just take on e2 and he's
won the queen and should win the game
pretty easily
this next trap is also one of my
favorite traps out of these because it's
actually very easy to miss
so this occurs in the scandinavian which
is e4 d5
so takes takes knight c3 queen g8
so this isn't a very popular move in the
scandinavian
more common moves include queen e5
queen d6 and queen a5
but this line still does show up every
now and then
so white plays knight f3 black plays
knight f6
white plays bishop g4 y plays bishop c4
black plays bishop g4 and although black
has been playing very natural moves
black is completely lost in this
position and the reason for that is
because white plays knight e5
so this is actually kind of a similar
theme to the legales trap which you may
know
where white plays a move that looks like
it hangs its queen
but it really creates a double attack on
f7
so black has a few options of course if
he takes the queen then bishop f7 is
checkmate
if he tries protecting the the f7 pawn
white can just sack his queen and if you
take back then
checkmate so the best move is to play
bishop e6 but the problem with this is
white can just take
and castle after which he's much better
or winning
because black has very bad pawns white
has an active knight
and he has better development
so there's only really one other option
of of course if black plays something
like e6 just trying to protect this pawn
white can take on g4 and he's up a piece
so black's last attempt is to play like
queen d4
and the easiest way of winning this
position in my opinion is to just take
on f7
black black should play king to d8 and
knight takes g4 it doesn't matter which
way black takes if you take to the queen
you can just trade queens
and black white can play something like
bishop e6 or just g4 continuing
development
and in this position he's upon he has
more active pieces and better
development
and not to mention the black can't
castle
so yeah that's this trap
and here is the ninth trap and this one
occurs in the caro khan defense
which is an opening i actually play so
it starts as e4
c6 knight c3 and the most common move is
to play
d4 here but white is going to intend to
play the two knights
so g5 knight f3 so this begins the two
nights variation of the caro khan
so black plays d takes e4 which isn't
the best move it's not
bad really but it's not the best and
bishop g4 here is the main line
so if block plays g takes e4 then knight
takes e4
and black should play something like
knight f6
but instead he plays bishop f5 which is
very similar to the classical carol khan
so if he plays knight g3 bishop g6
and this looks very similar to a
position in the classical caracon which
i can show you right now
so the classical character goes like
this
so if you look at this position and
this position you'll notice there's only
one difference really
and it's that in this position white's
pawn is on d4
but in this position white's pawn isn't
on d4 but it's his turn
so if white were to play d4 here
then these two positions would actually
be the exact same
but since white hasn't played d4 he can
utilize his extra tempo and play a very
powerful move
he can play the move h4 and this is
another
common idea in the classical caricon but
it's even stronger here trying to trap
the bishop
so black will probably play h6 just
making room for his bishop
and here white should play knight to e5
and this is trying to force the bishop
to h7 so
black shouldn't actually play his bishop
to h7 he should play move like queen d6
but if you take
white's not winning but he has a better
position because he has the two bishops
and he just has an easy game in general
so instead white black will probably
play bishop h7
and here let you play queen to h5 which
is threatening checkmate on f7
so black should play g6 here just
stopping the mate
after which white white will play bishop
to c4
and this isn't the best move the best
move is to play queen f3
but in my opinion this move is
definitely easier to play
so bishop c4 then
black plays e6 just stopping the mate
threat
and queen to e2 this creates another
trap threat and the idea is that if
black just continues developing then you
can play knight f7
and if he takes you can take here with
checkmate
but even if black sees that threat and
if he plays a move that stops the threat
such as for example
queen to e7 then white should just
continue developing and he is better
here
you can play something like a4 stopping
this topping these b5 ideas and also
gaining space
black can play something like knight f6
or not c3 sorry
b3 i can play b3 continuing development
and white has a solid
and comfortable position
trap number 10 occurs in the dutch
defense and this is probably my least
favorite trap out of all of these
but it still can occur d4
f5 and the best move here is to play c4
and it's also one of the most common
and black white's plans are just to play
something like knight c3
probably g3 bishop g2 etc
but instead white plays bishop to g5 and
after
black's next move you might see why i
don't like this trap as much as the
others
and it's because black will play h6 just
attacking the bishop
bishop h4 and in blitz and bullet games
white black might play g5 which is
actually a really bad move here
and he might think that after bishop g3
he's trapping your bishop on
g3 and in most in most openings
pretty much every opening except really
the dutch this would be true and white
would be pretty much losing
but in this opening white can play e3
and the idea is that he's threatening
queen h5 mate so black takes the bishop
that's mate
so if black just tries stopping the mate
by knight f6 you can take on f4
and you're up a pawn with a good
position because black king is pretty
weak
uh not that is not weak this is weak
so instead of playing knight to f6 black
might try h5
and the idea behind this is if you take
then he can try h4 trapping your bishop
again
but what you should do here is you
should play bishop to e2
and the idea behind this move is you can
take on h5 next
and if he tries to if he tries to take
your bishop once again you can take
followed by mate and if he tries to play
knight f6
intending to protect the pawn and then
go about his plan you can take on f4
and if he plays h4 just trying to trap
your bishop once again
you can take on g5 then if he takes here
now since his knight was on f6
you can take on f6 and if black takes
here
then you should just play bishop h5 and
try to draw the king out
so if black takes on f2 instead you can
just take on f2
if he takes back then you can just start
trying to
meet him
and white is winning here
so this trap is another trap for black
and this occurs in the french defense
specifically the fort knox variation
or actually this trap doesn't occur for
black whoops
so it starts as e4 e6 d4 d5 this is the
french defense
knight c3 so this is uh the main line
basically
and the most common news for black are
to play knight f6
and bishop b4 but instead black plays g
takes e4 which is less common but it's
not really bad
so white takes and black plays bishop to
d7
and the idea is that if black continues
development like he does in the if white
continues developing like he does in the
game
then black will play bishop to c6 and
the idea is
he wants to trade off this this light
squared bishop which is generally the
bad bishop in the french
and he wants to exchange it for this
knight on e4 which is pretty good
so this is what happens in the trap
white plays bishop g3
and black should take on e4 here
following through with his plan
bun said he plays knight f6 which is
already a bad move
and it seems very natural which it makes
it kind of surprising
so white takes on f6
and black has two options here you can
take with the pawn
or if he wants to he can take with the
queen which is a very bad move
so if he takes the queen then like you
play bishop g5
and you might think here that this is a
blunder because
although it does look like it traps the
queen black can play bishop f3
and if you recapture you can just take
on g5
but once you're in this position white
can play a really strong move queen to
d2
and this continues the trap on the queen
because white has protected his bishop
and but the queen has no other squares
to go to
so this sort of motif can occur in many
different openings not just the french
so if black does pretty much anything
white will take
and if black tries to take on d4 with
this queen then white has a discovered
attack which is bishop b5
so if you just moved your queen back
then you can take
and if you play knight c6 then the
knights pin so you can just take on d4
so the final trap occurs in the roy
lopez
and this one is for black as well
so it starts as e4 e5
knight f3 knight f6
bishop b5 knight f6
and this is the berlin defense which is
very popular
so white plays d3 which is not the most
common move
the most common move is to play castles
but he plays d3
and here the best move is probably to
play bishop c5
but in this trap white plays knight c to
e7
and this is actually like a common line
not super common
not as common as bishop c5 but it's not
like a bad move or anything it's not the
best
but it still works and the trap is if
white plays knight takes e5
and it might seem obvious that white
might realize that black is setting a
trap
but actually even if he spends a bit of
time here it it's not super easy to see
black's next idea
so if black does play if white does play
knight takes e5
then black can play c6 winning a piece
and the idea is that
if black if white just moves his piece
then you can play queen a5
and no matter what white does you can
take on e5 next move
so black has one id white has one idea
left to try to save his piece and that's
to play knight c4
and that's writing a smothered mate on
d6 so this would be a blunder because of
knight to d6
so instead white can play very
black and play very simple tress here he
can just play knight to g6
protecting this mate because of the
bishop and once
once white moves his bishop back black
can play b5
and this is a pawn fork because it's
attacking these two pieces
if he moves the knight black will take
the bishop
and if he moves the bishop black will
take the knight
so those are my 12 opening traps for
today
i hope you enjoyed and i hope these can
come up in your games at some point
thank you for watching
[Music]
you